hi Audi thanks for having me um I'm
super excited to talk on subba and duck
DB analyzing everything everywhere all
at once but I also have to say I'm so
honored to be in just a power session
with so many duck DB enthusiasts it's
cool to see all the
variations uh I'm excited to lean into
the PW and go deep on python
uh all right so just a little background
my name is Michael
Chow uh I did a PhD in cognitive
psychology uh I do open source data
tools at pait uh focus on python
tools um and I have two beautiful cats
Bandit and moon
dog so that those aren't related at all
to the topic what I want you to think
about is when you start a data analysis
in
Python um if if you're like me do you
think about the question what data frame
do I use I think it's in R you usually
kind of have it figured out but in
Python you have quite a few options so
you could import pandas or you could
import
polers or you could also bring in duct
DB and work that into your
analysis and I find the options really
exciting I really like to have a lot of
different options for analysis but I
also find parts of it really
overwhelming and I think the reason is
that depending on the data frame you use
everything changes so you have to go to
a new documentation site um all the
operations are different sometimes
subtly different um so you might maybe
start with pandas and go there and learn
its methods and then you might switch to
polers I I've really been enjoying
polers a lot and you'll notice that it
looks eerily similar to the panda site
except everything's slightly ever so
slightly
different and let's just say you keep
going and you decide to go with pandas
and you just want to concatenate a
couple columns so that means you want to
take um you know the strings in X and
you just want to um concatenate them
with Y you could use uh DF dox do SDR
doat don't ask me to say that again uh
and uh pass it dfy and that'll
concatenate it so you'll get two rows
AC BD I had to check that uh but that's
exactly what you'll get um so great
that's fine but then let's say you
decide to use polers and um you decide
to do something a little bit similar and
so you notice there's a concat method um
so there let's say you try the concat
method as it turns out you'll get an
error and the reason is concat in poers
actually Aggregates so it sort of um
pastes all the letters in your series
and actually the argument you passed
makes no sense to polers and it's mad at
you um I find this really uh I actually
love all the options they give me but I
find this switching this sort of split
brain nature of working with data really
challenging in Python and I leaning into
into the movie everything everywhere all
at once I sort of I want to try coining
a pattern for this I think this is the
everything bagel pattern it's the
pattern where you have a data tool but
you also want to kind of stuff in
everything people might want to do with
it so you take every possible method and
you add it on and I I I actually again I
love options I love that I can do a lot
with it but I find it really kind of
overwhelming when I'm switching off
between things that I'm switching off
kind of the whole
world
um I think one neat thing oh so just
summ yeah you can't use really use
Panda's methods on polar's data you can
but there's this like interchange and
that's really vexing to me um so let's
let's keep going though I think one
really neat thing I've been using a lot
of duck DB and I think the really neat
thing is you can run duck DB on either
pandas or polers you can just use duck D
DB functions DCT DB has its own docs so
it's not totally innocent from this me
like um docs thing but I I really like
using duck DB I find the one challenge
is that I I see people write a lot of
SQL in Python strings um and so this is
kind of a weird tradeoff um if you're
doing it in
Python um so one really neat thing I
think about suban duct DB is you can use
deer syntax to generate SQL for duck DB
and you could still harness the power of
the duck so in this case you would do a
little bit of setup um right now we're
using SQL Alchemy to sort of create a
connection to duck DB and then D plier
style you would create a tibble so this
is similar to how D DB plier connects to
database
tables um and then you can feed it into
something like mut
and it might actually turn turn give you
back that exact same sort of sequel that
can cat statement um so I I really like
this approach because I get um the
syntax and the grammar of deer but the
power of um duck DB and I think
especially in Python that's really
helpful to have that um escape hatch you
might notice though there's one weird
thing that's going to be a big topic
here which is uh this is a quirk subba
actually is translating Panda's
methods um I think going back to that
doc situation I don't want to add new
Methods at all like I you already have
half a dozen doc sites to worry about I
in my mind it was uh subba is originally
built on uh pandas to manipulate pandas
data and so it just used the panda
methods I didn't want to create a whole
new Doc site for people
um but it's a little bit weird when
you're working with duck DB now if you
think about it if you're a person
working with duck DB it's weird to be in
the duck DB docs and then have to
actually switch to Panda methods that
get translated back to duck DB um I feel
like it's the same sort of split brained
problem as the sort of pandas poers
everything bagel methods
situation and so what I want to talk
about today is an approach I've been
working on called duck Ops which is the
idea of what if you could just import
the duck DB functions into Python and
just use those now it's sort of all duck
DB and you don't have to worry about
this weird translational docs thing you
could hopefully stick mostly with the
duck DB docs um and still get D plier
syntax in Python and I've been really
enjoying this approach um so just to
recap uh I think you've heard a lot
about duct DB duct DB is really neat
it's fast it can read all kinds of
things it's got really cool Cutting Edge
sequel syntax um that it's added the
idea with duck Ops is that um you should
be able to just read the duck DB
functions in and use them in Python and
there are a lot of really neat
advantages to that and then subba is the
deer part of being able to mutate and
filter and select
all right but I want to really focus on
this thing this move from methods to
functions I think as our user as if
there are a lot of our users in this
room you probably already appreciate
functions because it's most of what you
use um when you're analyzing data but um
what if I told you the thing on the left
methods are probably the dominant way of
working with data in Python so I I want
to focus on why this is a really big
deal
um and it goes back to this the
everything
bagel all right so I'm I'm going to talk
about how functions are sort of
alternative
realities um and then I want to focus a
little bit more on methods and some of
their limits and then some more advanced
features that you can do with duck
DB all right so first functions are
alternative
realities uh in the movie everything
everywhere all at once uh we we follow a
character Evelyn as she experiences many
different universes in one she has hot
dogs for
fingers in another she's a cat
person and in yet another she's a rock
on a
mountain and a big challenge is Evelyn
finds these alternative realities
overwhelming um when you move through
these different realities you might feel
a bit fractured and
overwhelmed uh because there's a whole
Universe of Alternatives out there and
they can really creep up on you and get
you I think about it like this I think
that there are so many things you can do
with data and it's worth diving into
every single one whether it's like
strings or dates or nested things which
is a crazy topic I think that there are
a lot of talks at posit comp on these
specific areas um we've heard talks
about working with dates that are really
in depth um and there's a library
stringr just dedicated to string
stuff
um so there's all these functions
there's all these sort of lives you can
live in data analysis and I'm sure you
know a date time person who's gone
weirdly deep into date times and they're
uh disheveled when they come out you
know they're ranting about I don't know
Epoch and different things they're
worlds out there in Duck Ops each of
these is just a subm module you can
import from um and I think this is
really helpful it's dumb but it's really
helpful to explore and find the
different things you might want to
use
um so I think a big advantage of all
these functions is they're really easy
to Tinker with you can just import
concat and you can see what happens so
um concat ABC is ABC see that's great I
love that concat with a polar series is
a polar series that's like pretty handy
to figure out what's going to happen um
one interesting thing is with the subba
um underscore it returns a lazy
expression and you can use that inside
um these sort of like lazy queries in
interesting ways another nice thing
about functions is you can just look up
docs off them so from python I can just
figure out what canat does when con
cat's tucked inside a string it's really
hard to figure out you kind of have to
go find other
ways um functions are really
discoverable I'm going to attempt to
play this I don't even know where my
there it is um this is just showing
looking things up it's not really fancy
but when you're in the middle of a data
analysis you kind of want to know your
options really fast so I'm this is not
exciting at all but it is exciting to
me
um all right I don't know where I guess
my cursor lives here now so um the other
thing is functions work great
programmatically so if you want to say
change how concat works so this is
actually concat WS which is how duck DB
says with
separator um I don't know I put that in
air quotes you can modify the behavior
of a function so in Python this is a
partial this is saying like the
separator is always a dash and now we
have a dash concat and that's all it
does uh it's dumb but it
works we'll get we'll get into methods
where it doesn't work in a little bit so
um the thing is you can swap in
Alternatives so here if we don't want
concat we can just import a new concat
from a new package and suddenly we have
another
version so just to recap you can really
easily Tinker across things it's easy to
discover functions to program them and
to swap in alternatives
in contrast methods the everything bagel
pattern um methods are a bit tricky to
work with they sort of put everything on
the data and it's nice you can look it
up via a dot but there are some
downsides one is that you end up with a
lot of docs people tend to
reproduce
methods the other is is that um if you
wanted to put a concat say on a panda
series you would actually have to do
something really we weird and kind of
violent to it you would have to mutate
it so you would just take the series and
you would actually just kind of shove
concat in there uh it's a really weird
only the owner of a class can really put
methods on it in a normal way um the
other thing is you can't change the
first argument a method is like a
function that loves its first argument
so a panda series isn't it weird like
you can Kink Kat the string ABC to
something but on a panda series you
actually can't do that because the
series is all always the first thing so
it's surprisingly
hard um the last is you can't really
program so we saw you could partial the
concat function um this isn't really
easy or fun or desirable with methods
you just sort of can't do
it um a lot of people will say method uh
apologists will say what about method
chains they're super convenient you can
take this D wood sandwich on the left
this weird this deep nested set of
function calls and you can turn into
this nice chain I agree that I think
that's really
important um subba tries to work around
this with function change just this pipe
syntax um so you can pipe functions into
each other so it's tough because method
chaining is a part of python so you get
it in the language but this is an
attempt to kind of get the same thing um
um with
functions just a recap methods are a
little bit hard to discover everybody
has their own docs for methods a
function just has one dock string um
Alternatives you need to actually mutate
classes to add new methods onto them and
the last is Method chains are a really
handy thing hopefully pipe chains this
concept can get you pretty
close all right so just di deeper I'm
GNA gloss
go through these very fast I think duck
DB I just to summize has some really
cool syntax and some really Advanced SQL
it can do so here this is actually that
Dash arrow is a Lambda there's all these
interesting constructs they have I think
in Duck Ops a big challenge is going to
be reproducing that so here we can run
this list filter function and we do have
um syntax for Lambda does um and this is
also used in the D plier across so a lot
of the same stuff is
reused um secondly would you rather have
string R functions that's actually
pretty doable like you could create
hopefully it's not called string R Pi
but with just functions you could create
alternative functions you could create
string r or we could do it as a
team um all right so just to recap duct
DB is incredible it's fast it can read
all kind of files has Cutting Edge SQL
syntax duck Ops is this experiment in
trying to pull the duck DB functions out
and I really want to make the point
hopefully that these functions are
really useful and as functions there's a
lot you can do with them and then last
subba aims to be a deer port to Python
and hopefully can let you build up your
duck DB query and use it
programmatically from
python so I want to thank everybody that
helped uh Christa Adams who designed the
hex sticker which will make a proper hex
and not a squiggly hex I swear it um
Chris cardillo Anthony Baker and tons of
folks at posit who have helped and
supported this kind of work so thanks
and G functions functions
forever thank you we have a few
questions so the Zen of python says
there should only be one way to do it
would you say that the python data
ecosystem fails to live up to that
philosophy yeah I think that that's an
interesting
Mantra uh I mean that's the funny thing
about methods is that your like your
first attempt at a method lives forever
because it lives on your data so I would
almost flip it and say with methods you
only get one attempt but actually if you
look at the history of the Tidy verse uh
packages like string R and lubridate and
all the failed versions of those things
um it's really clear that are innovated
through Alternatives and decoupling of
the functions that can act on data from
the data itself but I I agree it would
be nice to have one way to do thing but
sometimes you got to like search around
you know sure sure um does subber
support polar and pandas I mean we're
just we're basically Barling on Duck DB
at this point I think um I I would love
to support polar's Expressions actually
I think similar to extracting out duct
DB functions it would be cool to just
work directly on polar's Expressions but
I think it would involve a little bit of
rust uh scuba
diving um one more question uh is there
a data world that's not currently
supported by Duck Ops that you'd like to
see in there in the future a data oh I
mean there's all the like Geo fun
functions and I mean it seems like
there's a ton of stuff in duct DB so
this is really a first pass to see what
it would look like and how it would feel
to run I almost feel like I'm really
sold on the feel I like the functions
and so now I'm really interested in
exploring how do we really flesh that
out and see what it looks like to just
try to cover as much as possible if it's
useful thank you very much let's thank
Michael and all of our other speakers
again thanks